tienen la gráfica de fx y nos piden
determinar las ecuaciones de todas las
cintas verticales así que veamos que
está pasando y parece primero que en -5
hay un comportamiento muy peculiar por
ejemplo si nos aproximamos a menos cinco
por la izquierda por ejemplo menos siete
menos seis menos 6.5 nos harían menos
5.5 verdad son estos son valores más más
pequeños que menos 5 así que si nos
aproximamos por la izquierda parece que
la función se va a menos infinito en
cambio si nos aproximamos por la derecha
con menos 3 menos 4 menos 4.5 menos 4.75
la función parece crecer y crecer sin
sin un fin así que está parece que
tiende a infinito por la derecha así que
podemos concluir que menos 5 es un muy
buen candidato para hacer la ecuación de
una de las cintas otro lugar donde
parece que hay un comportamiento similar
en dos por ejemplo si nos aproximamos
por 11.5 1.75 y así sucesivamente la
función y parece irse hacia abajo y cada
vez más de hecho tiende a menos infinito
cuando nos aproximamos a dos por la
izquierda por el contrario si nos
aproximamos a dos por la derecha aunque
aquí hay un comportamiento como que como
que va oscilando un comportamiento
oscilatorio al final parece que tiende
también a menos infinito así que en dos
también es no acotada la función ahora
basta con que sea no acotada por alguno
de los dos lados para que ahí exista una
cinta está vertical en nuestro caso es
no acotada por ambos lados así que x
igual a 2 también es un candidato para
sí en total y vamos a comprobarlo ahí lo
tienen estábamos bien